اهلا بكم في هذه التغطيه المستمره كل عام
وانتم بخير ونواصل تغطيتنا للشان السوداني
والى العناوين
باقي النار تخرق صمت الهدنه المعلنه في
السودان وسط اتهامات متبادله الجيش يعلن
السيطره على وسط الخرطوم بعد دفعه بقوات
مشاه الى الشوارع والدعم السريع تؤكد انها
ما زالت تحافظ على مواقعها العسكريه
الله اكبر ولله الحمد ومع انقضاء اول ايام
عيد الفطر معاناه انسانيه مع استمرار
المعارك وفي حديث للجزيره نقابه الاطباء
تصف الوضع بالكارثي بعد خروج عدد من
المستشفيات عن الخدمه والصحه العالميه
تعلن ان عدد قتل الاشتباكات تجاوز ال 400
ومع ازدياد الغموض بشان مواجهات السودان
مزيد من المخاوف الغربيه بشان الرعايه
والبعثات الدبلوماسيه واشنطن تقول انها
نشرت قوات امريكيه في الجوار السوداني
تحسبا لاي اجراء طارئ وتصريحات اوروبيه
تقول انه لا خيارات جيده حاليا لتنفيذ
عمليات اجلال
لم يكن لها اعلان الجيش السوداني عن
الموافقه على هدنه تستمر ثلاثه ايام حتى
اتهم الناطق باسمه قوات الدعم السريع بشن
ما وصفه بهجوم عشوائيه على القياده العامه
والقصر الرئاسي في المقابل كان المستشار
القانونيه لقوات الدعم السريع قال انه
سيتم احترام الهدنه الا في حالات الدفاع
عن النفس وفق تعبيرهم حديث ياتي وتضارب في
الانباء بشان السيطره على بعض المواقع
الجيش السوداني قال ان وسط العاصمه باكمله
تحت سيطرته اما قوات الدعم السريع فتقول
انها تحافظ على مواقعها العسكريه
معنا من وسط الخرطوم مراسلنا هيثم من مروي
الشمال السودان مراسلنا اسامه سيد احمد
اهلا بكما نبدا
بهيثم في الخرطوم لنرى الاجواء مع هذا
الحديث عن هدنه جديده
نعم محمد بعد اسبوع حافل بالمواجهات
العسكريه الشريسه تلتقط الخرطوم انفاسها
الان في هذا المساء بعد ان هدات الاجواء
وهدا صوت البنادق هنا خاصه في منطقه وسط
الخرطوم المنطقه التي شهدت اشرس المواجهات
واعنفها في خلال الاسبوع الماضي الان
الاجواء هادئه الناس هنا رغم ان نحن في
الليل طبعا الليل يصعب فيه التحرك ويصعب
فيه
التجوال وبالتالي لا يستطيع الناس
الاستفاده من هذه الهدنه في هذا الليل
ولكن ساعات المقبله ساعات الصباح ربما هي
التي ستحمل
البشريات بالنسبه للسكان بان يخرجوا من
منازلهم ويقضوا حاجاتهم هذا اذا طبعا لم
تتطور هذه الاتهامات المتبادله بخرق هذه
الهدنه الى مواجهات مجددا
تعطل العمليه الهدنه كما حصل في السابق
الان كل الامان معقوده على هذه الهدنه على
ان تلتزم الاطراف بهذه الهدنه وعلى ان
تعمل هذه الهدنه في تحسين الوضع الانساني
والوضع الصحي المتردي وان تساهم في خروج
المحاصرين من مواقع القتال وان تكون هذه
بدايه خطوه لربما اتفاق السلام شامل او
وقف شامل لاطلاق النار تعقبه ربما
مفاوضات لحل هذه الازمه وحل هذا الاشكال
هذا ما يتمناه البعض وما يتمناه الوسطاء
انه الذين سعوا من اجل اقناع الاطراف في
الدخول في هذه الهدنه ولكن يظل الحذر قائم
يظل تظل المخاوف موجوده من تجدد هذه
المواجهات بالنسبه لتكرارها في السابق
وبالتالي يعني كل المؤشرات تظل مفتوحه
يعني تثبت الايام المقبله
هذه الهدنه فعلا لديها ارضيه صلبه ولديها
يعني وجود في افضل واقع خاصه ان هناك حتى
الان لم يتم الاتفاق على اليات محدده
لمراقبه هذه هي الهدنه ووقف اطلاق النار
وكيفيه متابعتها ولكن من حيث المبدا
الاطراف قالت بناسه تلتزم بهذه الهدنه وهو
ما يعني سنراه في مقبل الساعات المقبله ان
شاء الله نعم لنرى الاجواء في
اسامه خاصه وان مصداقيه الهدن الان اصبحت
مطروحه بالحاح
[ضحك]
محمد
المنطقه هنا منطقه مروي لم تكن هناك حاجه
الى هدنه لان اصوات البنادق قد صمطت منذ
اكثر من ثلاثه او اربعه ايام خلال كل هذه
الفتره نتحدث عن هدوء تام يسود مدينه مروي
والقرى المجاوره لهذه المدينه بعد اعلان
سيطره الجيش السوداني على كامل المدينه
طبعا
ومحيط ومطار مروي الدولي والقاعده الجويه
العسكريه التابعه للجيش السوداني في منطقه
مروي
نشير هنا اننا تحدثنا قبل قليل مع شهود
عيان ومصادر محليه اكدت لنا ان يعني
مجموعات مسلحه تقوم بعمليه بعمليات نهب في
طريق شريان الشمال الرابط ما بين ام درمان
وبنقله هذا الشارع فيه يعني نشاط لمجموعات
مسلحه بحسب شهود قامت بعمليات نهب لعدد من
المواطنين
واخذت سياراتهم تحت تهديد السلاح واخذت
يعني كميات من الاموال من المواطنين وبعض
المواطنيات الثمينه اذا هذا هو الحال في
هذه المنطقه قالوا ان اغلب هذه الحوادث
حوادث النهبه تمت شمال مدينه ام درمان
باكثر من مئه كيلو متر هذه المجموعات التي
تنشط في عمليات النهب طبعا هي
انعكاس طبيعي لحاله السيوله الامنيه التي
تجدها هذه المناطق وانعكاس طبيعي يعني
الواقعه الامني في هذه في هذه المنطقه
خاصه بعد اعلان الجيش السوداني بانه يقوم
بمطالبه ما سماها جيوب المتمردين في عده
مناطق في الولايه
نتحدث منذ عده ايام عن هدوء تام يسود هذه
واليوم الاول من عيد الفطر المبارك يعني
صلى المصلون هنا صلاه صلاه العيد
وكالمعتاد في ساحات العامه
والميادين والمساجد ولكن طعم هذا العيد
كان مختلفا بطبيعه الحال عن كل الاعياد
الماضيه حيث جاء في اعقاب اشتباكات مسلحه
كثيفه ونيران اطلاق نار كثيف في محيط مطار
مروي قبل ان يعلن الجيش كامل سيطرته على
محيط المطار وحتى هذه اللحظه ولكن هناك
هدوء تعمي اسود هذه المنطقه وبالتالي
الجيش يقول انه يطارد يستمر في مطارده
جيوب متفرقه هنا وهناك وقال انه يصر على
انهاء ما سماه التمرد في منطقه مروي ينضم
الينا الان حسن رزاق من من ام درمان
ونفس السؤال عن الاجواء الحاليه
الاجواء الحاليه هدوء نسبي
نسمع بين الحين والاخر صوت لمضادات طائرات
والتي قد ترد على طلعات جويه لسلاح الجو
السوداني وايضا قد ترد على قذائف ومدافع
يطلقها الجيش السوداني على بعض من المواقع
قوات الدعم السريع طبعا فقط للتوضيح نحن
في الاتحاد في ام درمان
المواجهات المسلحه هنا بين طرفي النزاع
ليست مواجهات على الارض ليست هناك وجود
حدود عسكريه لكن المواجهات يمكن
توصيفها بحسب ما اشار لنا السكان هنا انها
عباره عن مواجهات جويه او مواجهات عبر
القذف البعيد هناك بعض القواعد للجيش
السوداني هناك تقصف عن طريق القبائل
والمدافع لمقرات خاصه بقوات الدم السريع
والتي ترد عبر المضادات وايضا طلعات جويه
لسلاح الجو ايضا يتم الرد عليها
عبر المضادات بالتالي هذه هي طبيعه
المواجهات على القلب في المنطقه التي
اتواجد فيها الان في الفتحات الان قبل
ثانيه اسمع ايضا اصوات المضادات الطائرات
وبالتالي هذا يعني ان المواجهات على هذا
النمط او على هذه الطبيعه لا زالت مستمره
طبعا هذا يشكل يسبب اشكال للسكان
المتواجدين هنا بحسبرونا ان اصوات هذه
المضادات واصوات هذه المدافع قد تثير
الفزع لدى السكان سيما الاطفال والنساء
وايضا اشكال اخر عندما تصطدم القذائف
والمدافع مع المضادات التي تطلق للرد
عليها كان يخرج منها شظايا قد تسقط على
المناطق الماهوله بالسكان هنا او هناك
وبالتالي هذا هو الاشكال الموجود حاليا في
المنطقه التي انا اتواجد فيها بحيث ممار
وبحيث ما اخبرنا السكان لكن الوضع هنا
استقرار نسبي وامني الناس ينشرون بشكل
طبيعي او بشبه طبيعي مقارنه المناطق
الموجوده في الخرطوم او جنوب الخرطوم كما
رصدنا البارحه هنا المحال شبه مفتوحه لكن
ايضا ينقصها التموين وينقصها الامداد
والاحتياجات الغذائيه سيما ان كافه
الامداد والتامين الذي ياتي الى هذه
المنطقه وياتي من الخرطوم والخرطوم هي
بشبه مغلقه وبالتالي عدم هذا يؤثر سلبا
على هذه المناطق لكن على اي حال تشهد
استقرار النسبي مقارنه بالمناطق المختلفه
شكرا جزيلا للثلاثي هيثم اويت من الخرطوم
حسن رزاق من ام درمان واسامه سيد احمد من
مروي
وفي اليوم السابع للاشتباكات في السودان
العمليات العسكريه للجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع تتركز في العاصمه الخرطوم المنطقه
الجنوبيه من العاصمه الخرطوم هي التي تشهد
العمليات العسكريه بشكل اساسي خلال
الساعات القليله الماضيه وتحديدا احياء
الصحافات وجبر والمدينه الرياضيه التي
تحتوي على معسكر للدعم السريع الجيش
السوداني يقول انه ينفذ عمليات تمشيط من
اجل ما وصفه بطرد الدعم السريع من المناطق
الواقعه بين نهري النيل الازرق والابيض
والتي تمتد لنحو عشره كيلومترات كما تتركز
العمليات في شارع الستين الذي يربط
المنطقه الجنوبيه للخرطوم بوسط العاصمه
وفي منطقه المسعوديه بين ولايتي الخرطوم
والجزيره اندلعت مواجهات بين الدعم السريع
والجيش خصوصا في مصانع شركه جهاد حيث افاد
مصدر في الشركه للجزيره ان الجيش يطارد
الدعم السريع بعد محاوله فاشله لاقتحام
المصانع
هذا وتتقطع الاشتباكات في وسط الخرطوم
وتحديدا في محيط المطار والقصر الجمهوري
ومحيط القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه
هذا و يفرض تسليح كل طرف في الازمه
السودانيه شكل التحرك الميدانيه فبينما
يتميز الجيش بتسليح ثقيل ومتوسط يمكنه من
التفوق في المعارك الواسعه النطاق تستخدم
قوات الدعم السريع اسلحه خفيفه في الغالب
ما يتيح لها سرعه التحرك والمناوره لكن مع
استمرار القتال تتبدل تكتيكات الطرفين
تبعا للتطورات الميدانيه لنتابع تفاصيل
المناوره الميدانيه للطرفين
يعتبر الجيش السوداني من الجيوش المتوسطه
من ناحيه العدد والعده يعتمد في تسليحه
على اسلحه الطيران القتالي والهجومي
والمدفعيه والدبابات والمدرعات وهو تسليح
يعتبر ثقيلا ومتوسطا كما هو حال الجيوش
النظاميه التقليديه
اما قوات الدعم السريع فتعتمد في تسليحها
بشكل اساسي على عربات رباعيه الدفع لكنها
لا تحمل سوى اسلحه متوسطه وخفيفه تتيح لها
سرعه التحرك الميداني
يحتم نوع الاسلحه التي بحوزه كل طرف شكل
التحرك الميداني وتكتيكات القتال يعطي
سلاح الجو تفوقا ميدانيا بارزا لصالح
الجيش السوداني في المواجهات واسعه النطاق
اضافه لسلاح المدفعيه
استخدم الجيش قدراته الجويه في بدايه
المعارك لاستهداف مقرات الدعم السريع في
الخرطوم وبعض الولايات
وبمسانده المدفعيه تمكنت القوات النظاميه
من الحاق خسائر كبيره بالدعم السريع
وجود مقرات للدعم السريع في الخرطوم اتاح
لها امكانيه قتال الجيش في اكثر المناطق
استراتيجيه العاصمه لكن مع استخدام سلاح
الطيران خسرت قوات الدعم السريع قواعد
خلفيه مسانده لها
فانتقلت لتكتيك قتالي تتميز به عاده
القوات غير النظاميه في اي مواجهه
مرونه الحركه وهي من مميزات قوات الدعم
السريع خصوصا في المواجهات داخل المدن
الجيش بدوره طوعا من طريقه عمله تحول لنشر
اعداد اكبر من جنوده في نقاط المواجهه
مستعينا بالمدرعات الخفيفه في وقت ستكون
حرب شوارع
وهذا ما اعلنته القوات المسلحه قالت انها
نشرت الافا من افرادها في احياء العاصمه
لمطارده ما وصفته ببئر الجماعات المتمرده
معنا من عمان اللواء فايز دويريا الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجيه اهلا وسهلا بك كل
عام وانتم بخير هذا الاختلاف في التكتيكات
بين الجيش والدعم السريع ما تاثيره عمليا
على الارض
يعني هي دعنا نقول يطلق عليها الحرب غير
المتناظره او الحرب غير التقليديه
وبالتالي على الجيش السوداني ان يطور من
اداء العمليات ومن المقاربه المتبع لانه
لا يمكن يعني لا هي تقع بين حرب المدن
والحرب
الهجينه لماذا لانها لا تقاتل بطريقه حرب
المدن المعروفه تاريخيا يعني لا يمكن ان
نقارن ما يجري في الخرطوم بما جرى في
الموصل وطريقه قتال داعش
والاستعدادها لان تقاتل من بيت الى بيت لا
الان هذه تقاتل باليات دفع رباعي تتحرك من
شارع الى شارع من نقطه الى نقطه وبالتالي
هي عمليات كرو وفر اكثر منها عمليات معارك
صداميه هذا يفرض على الجيش السوداني ان
يطور من اداء الميداني بالدفع باليات
متوسطه وليست ثقيله حتى يكون لديها قابليه
حركه ويكون لديها سرعه رد الفعل ولكن
احيانا حضره اللواء احيانا الجيش السوداني
يستعمل الطائرات هل هذا ذو جدوى
هذا هذا ما كنت
ساكمل الحديث في هذا النقطه ان بما ان هذا
هو الواقع قابليه حركه متميزه لاليات دفع
رباعي خفيفه تقوم بعمليات مباغته وهجوم
وانكفاء وتخفي وبالتالي
الاليه التقليديه لاداره المعركه من قبل
جيش نظامي باعتماد اليات ثقيله هذه لن
تجدي نفعا لماذا لا يمكن اعاده تجاوزها
وتغطيها بمعنى اخر قد تتقدم هذه الاليات
ولكن تندفع اليات الدفع الرباعي من شوارع
فرعيه الى مناطق خلفيه اذا لاحظ الجيش
يستخدم كلمه تمشيط اي بمعنى اخر تطهير
كامل هنا عليه ان كما قلت يوظف اليات
متوسطه واليات خفيفه اكثر منها اليات
ثقيله عليه عن
يزيد من
اعتماده على الطائرات وخاصه الطائرات
العموديه وليس الطائرات الطائرات المجنحه
قد تستخدم على اهداف الرئيسيه لماذا لا
نحجم القنابل قد تصل الى 500 باوند هنا
عليه ان يوظف ويستخدم طائرات ميل 24 وهي
ما يطلق عليه قال الدبابات او قانس
المركبات هذه قد يكون لها دورا فاعلا في
تطوير عملياته لكسب الوقت من اجل تحقيق
انجازات والا ستكون مضنيه شكرا مكلفه
ماديا وزمنيه شكرا لك وفائزه من عمان
ينضم الينا الان من الخرطوم الريح محمد
صادق القيادي في الحريه والتغيير المجلس
المركزي اهلا وسهلا بك الان مع هذه الهدنه
الجديده
هل يمكن ان تصمت
تحيه لك للساده المشاهدين الرحمه والخلود
لشهداء الشعب السوداني الذين صلاتوا منا
يوم السبت الى هذا اليوم 7 ايام سابقا
من مصلحه السودانيين ان تصمت هذه الهدنه
لثلاثه ايام لانها هي النافذه الامل
الوحيد الان في ظل الاوضاع الانسانيه
والحياتيه المعقده السودانيين في العاصمه
قرطوم ومناطق الاشتباك الاخرى وكذلك الان
هي نافذه الامل الوحيد ايضا
بحسم المعرفه من احد الطرفين القادم
واعتقد ان مستوى هذه الحرب بهذه الطريقه
سوف تستمر
بشكل عام يعني
عفوا اذا راى البعض بان الدعم السريع ربما
هو اقل التزاما من الجيش اقل التزاما اقصد
بان الجيش ربما لديه قياده قادره على فرض
الالتزام بوقف اطلاق النار او بالهدنه
بينما الدعم السريع الان بحكم تنقلاته
سريعه بين الاحياء قد لا ينضبط بالكامل هل
هذا صحيح
التحديد من الذي
لا ينضبط الان من الصعوبه المكان لاي شخص
ان يحدد من هو الذي بعده بخلق هذه الجمله
لذلك المرحله الثانيه من هذه الهدنه يجب
ان يكون هناك تسميه لاليه مراقبه لهذه
الهدنه من شخصيات مدنيه حقوقيه وطبيه كي
تستطيع ان توفر
المسارات الطبيه وكذلك لكي ترصد
مدى الالتزام والجديه بالالتزام بهذه
الهدنه اعتقد ان الذي
من هو من الذي خرج الهدنه الى الان هي
مجرد اقوال لا احد يستطيع ان يجزم تماما
من الطرفين الذي يخرج الهدنه وهذا هو الذي
يقوض هذه الهدنه في في اوقات سابقه تم
اعلان الهدنه لمده 24 ساعه في مرتين وتم
تعاقب ل 72 ساعه قبل يوم من الان والان
الجيش اصدر بيانا وقالا
في هدنه لمده 72 ساعه هذا امر جيد لكن لكي
الالتزام بهذه الغنه وليس تكون هذه الهدنه
هدنه حقيقيه يجب ان تكون هنالك اليه
مراقبه لكن عفوا هل هل اليه المراقبه هذه
سهله لان هذه هذه تستلزم استعدادا معينا
وخبره معينه لا يستطيع ان يقوم بها اي طرف
من المؤهل لذلك
في الوضع الراهن المؤهل الوحيد لاليه هذه
المراقبه هم المدنيون من الفرضيين ومن
الاطباء ومن السياسيين ايضا هنالك انتشار
كثير لهذه الفئات في مدن العاصمه الثلاث
وفي المناطق التي تنشط فيها الاشتباكات
[موسيقى]
ما زالت خدمه الاتصال متوفره
طرفين فقط انه اعتقد خطير لانه حاله ما
تندلع اي نوع من الاشتباكات سيخرج الى
الاعلام ببيانات بان الطرف الاخر هو الذي
خرج الهدنه وهذا يؤدي الى تدهور الاوضاع
كميه سريعا وانفلات الاشتباك وسنكون
مضطرين الى البحث مره اخرى فيها النجم
نعلي الهدنه اخرى وسنتفاوض لساعات طويله
وسنتواصل مع الطرفين لساعات طويله حتى
نسدد او نخرج بالتزام بهدنه اخرى وانا
اعتقد في حاله عدم الالتزام بهذه الهدنه
نحن نقضي
الحرب بسرعه
شكرا جزيلا لك
شكرا جزيلا لك الريح محمد الصادق من
الخرطوم
ومن الخرطوم كذلك ينضم الينا الان هشام
عثمان الشواني المتحدث باسم مبادره نداء
اهل السودان عندما نتحدث عن اليه مراقبه
للهدنه هل هذا امر يسير
مرحبا بك ومرحبا المشاهدين وكل عام والامه
الاسلاميه والعربيه والشعب السوداني بخير
في الحقيقه
اهليه لمراقبه الهدنه حاليا في اي حال من
الاحوال لانه الواضح
الطرفين الموجودين في في الميدان هم ما
على قدم المساواه ابدا
بالطبيعه اللي فيها مليشيا قياده التمرد
الان
في حمايه هذا البلاد وتقوم بدورها خطه
يعني مدروسه لحكم التعقيد الذي وضع فيه
قائد
الجيش
لهذه الدوله الطرف الاخر هو طرف يتسم
بالكثير من حقيقه يعني بكثير من العشوائيه
بكثير من غياب القياده عن العمل الميداني
وكذلك هذا الطرف هو يتمادى في ان يحول
البلاد الى بكره من العنف وبؤره من
الالتهابات
ويحاول ان يغطي على التراجع الميداني
الكبير الذي الذي وصل اليه
وبالتالي نحن نسمع احاديث هنا وهناك بعض
القوى الداخله السودان التي نحن في راينا
انها بطريقه خفيه تدعم موقف التمرد وهذه
القوه السياسيه هي القوه التي وقعت مع
قائد التمرد الاتفاق الايطالي هذه القوى
تقول ان توصف المعركه بغير وصفها السليم
ووصفها الحقيقي الذي نرايناه يوم خلال
عمليات هذا اليوم راينا احتشاد كبير جدا
للشعب السوداني
بالاجماع بالاجماع وراء هذا الجيش
استنكارا لعمليه التمرد استنكاره
الانتهاكاته وحسا
ولكن ولكن هذا التحليل هذا التحليل سيد
يعني يعني بعد اذنك نحاول ان نتغلب ايضا
على هذا التقطع للصوت حتى تكون المداخله
واضحه سيد هشام عثمان هذا التحليل يعني في
النهايه ان نحن امام جيش نظامي منضبط
وامام جهه اخرى انت تسميها متمرده او من
ليسيا اذا كانت هذه الجهه الثانيه غير
منضبطه معنى ذلك ان لا هدنه يمكن ان تصمت
في النهايه
هذا اللي حدث في الهدنه الاولى والهدنه
الثانيه هذه القوه المتمرده
في حال من الاحوال ان تتخلى عن سلوكها
لانه نقطه تفوقها والنقطه التي يعني
تدفعها للقتال منذ البدايه في الايام
الاولى في ساعات الاولى كان السلوك
الهجومي السلوك مرتبط
مرتبطها فشل مخططها الان هي تبحث عن فرصه
من اجل ان تلتقط انفاسها
او تبحث عن فرصه للعرض على اي حال على
المجتمع الدولي يعني يفهم هذه القوه جيدا
وهذه الخطوه تذهب بناء بطريقه مدروسه نحو
شكرا لك شكرا لك هشام عثمان الشواني من
الخرطوم
هذا وقد اعلنت القوى الوطنيه السودانيه
الموقعه على الاتفاق الايطالي مبادره دع
المؤقعون عليها طرفي المواجهات المسلحه
الى التحلي بالروح الوطنيه وتقديم كل
تنازل يحقن الدماء ويعينه ويعينه على
تحقيق الوفاق الوطني الشامل تضمنت هذه
المبادره دعوه للوصول الى وقف نهائي
ودائما لاطلاق النار وتحويل قضايا الخلاف
بينهما الى طاوله الحوار لاستكمال العمليه
السياسيه كما دعت المبادره الى تكوين لجنه
المشتركه تضم ممثلين الاطراف بالاضافه الى
ممثلينا لحركات الكفاح المسلح لمراقبه وقف
الاعمال العدائيه وتنسيق عمليات وقف اطلاق
النار النهائي وكذلك الاستعانه بالمنظمات
الانسانيه المحليه والدوليه لاغاثه
المحتاجين
وعلاج الجرحى
رحبت الاليه الثلاثيه المسهله للحوار في
السودان باعلان الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
وقفا لاطلاق النار لاستعاده الهدوء خلال
عيد الفطر وقالت الاليه ان اتفاق وقف
اطلاق النار سيسمحوا للمدنيين بالحصول على
المساعدات الضروريه مثل الغذاء والماء
والرعايه الطبيه وشددت الاليه الثلاثيه
على اهميه التوصل الى وقف طويل الامد
للاعمال العيديه من اجل جميع السودانيين
ومستقبلهم
قالت المندوبه الامريكيه لدى الامم
المتحده ليندا توماس غرينت ان الوضع في
السودان في تدهور مستمر كل دقيقه وانه لا
يوجد وقت
للطبيعه واضافت المندوبه الامريكيه في
تغريده ان على مجلس الامن تحرك فورا
وبصوره عاجله دعما للجهود الاقليميه
للمساعده في تسهيل وقف اطلاق النار
هذا ويخشى الشعب السوداني من دخول البلاد
في متاهه المفاوضات والحوار التي يدور
الحديث حولها وفكره المفاوضات تبدو ملغومه
لانها ستطرح سؤال الازمه الاشكالي التفاوض
حول ماذا تحديدا
من هذا المكان
عن السودان
السودان بدم انا
يروا الجيش السوداني اليوم نفسه مرغما على
خوض حربه التي لم يخضها من قبل وقد كانت
ايسر وقد كانت اقل كلفه انها كما يقول حرب
الضروره التي انشاها وجود قوه عسكريه
ضاربه نمت في كنف الدوله حتى اصبحت خطرا
عليها فقوات الدعم السريع بقياده الفريق
محمد حمدان حميدتي مثلت في نظري كثير من
العسكريين والمدنيين مهددا للدوله
السودانيه من جهه العسكريه ومن جهه
السياسه كذلك اذ لم يحدث في تاريخ الجيش
السوداني وتاريخ السودان منذ استقلاله ان
نشات قوه كثيره العتاد كثيره الجند تدير
شؤونها اسره تمويلا وتسليحا وتجريدا لها
في مهام مخارج السودان كما حدث للجيش
وللسودان خلال السنوات الاخيره من حكم
البشير ثم من بعد تحت قياده الفريق عبد
الفتاح برهان بصفته قائدا للجيش ورئيسا
لمجلس السياده
جرى التجارب الشعوب والحكم ان الدوله يكون
لها جيش واحد تحت قياده واحده السودان لم
يكن كذلك فقد باتت قوات الدعم السريع في
عين الجيش جمله نافره في العسكريه وفي
السياسه معه كانت بيانا صارخا فيما انتهت
اليه الدوله السودانيه من ضعف مؤسسي عسكري
وسياسي
المؤسسه الوحيده التي كانت تنمو في ظل
تراجع كل شيء في السودان هي قوات الدعم
السريع التي لم تستصحب اي مشروع سياسي او
فكري
تمت فكره واحده هي القوه نفسها وهي القوه
التي ستطلب السلطه ثمره لها فلطالما اتهم
حميتي بانهم تلا بفكره حيازه السلطه عن
طريق القوه فهي اداه ولا اداه له غيرها
والا ما حاجته الى انشاء قوه يزيد عدده
على مئه الف رجل تحت امرته وامراه اخيه
وقد استمر الاتهام له بانه كان ملحاحا في
طلب الحواضن كافلات القوه فزع يطرق ابواب
القبائل والعشائر بابا يبذل لهم الاموال
والعطايا بسخاء ثم بدا له ان زعماء
القبائل والعشائر لا يستطيعون قطع الطريق
الى اخرها وليسوا بقادرين على بلوره طموحه
السياسي في لغه صالحه للتسويق الداخلي
والخارجي
وما زال يجد في طلب الانصار حتى انتهى الى
خيمه الاتفاق الايطالي مقدما نفسه الراعي
الرسمي للمشروع الديمقراطي في السودان
ولعل وهما او حقيقه استقرت لدى بعض قطاعات
القوى المدنيه الحديثه فحواها لما لا يكون
حميدتي حمايتي ايضا في نسخه محدثه من
تجربته مع عمر البشير
وكان طبيعيا ان تقع الحرب التي لم يكن
منها بد بعد ان بلغت التناقضات العسكريه
والسياسيه نهاياتها العدميه ويقول الجيش
انه يحارب قياده قوه عسكريه كانت حتى امس
توصف بانها من القوى النظاميه في الدوله
ويحتل قائدها موقع نائب رئيس مجلس السياده
وبهذا المعنى فان الخطاب المؤسس لشرعيه
واخلاقيه الحرب من وجهه نظر الجيش هي انه
يقاتل قوه منه تمردت عليه وهذا التوصيف
بالكاد يترك مساحه لمتدخل بالحسنى او
بغيرها تاركا مصير السودان بين خيارين اما
انتصار الجيش انتصارا ساحقا تحل به كل
التناقضات العسكريه التي تسببت دعم السريع
بارتباطاته الخارجيه في وجودها واما ان
تنتصر قوات الدعم السريع على الجيش
فينهدئ اهم ركن في الدوله واخ مؤسسه لازمه
لامن الاوطان وبقائها هل تم خيار ثالث انه
خيار الحوار والدخول في مفاوضات برعايه
اقليميه او دوليه ثلاثيه او رباعيه او
خماسيه او اكثر من ذلك لكن تجارب البعثات
الدوليه
والمبعوثين والرعاه على كثرتهم ما اسعف
التجاربهم في جلب السلام الى اليمن ولا
الى ليبيا ولا الى سوريا او الصومال ولا
غيرها من الدول في اثيوبيا مثلا رفض ابي
احمد رئيس الوزراء الاثيوبي في حربه ضد
المتمردين من التقراي رفضت تدخل الاتحاد
الافريقي في الشان الاثيوبي قال لا وفي
عاصمه بلاده اديس ابابا تخفق اعلام
الاتحاد الافريقي وبالطبع لم يتجرا احد
على دعوه الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن الى
الجلوس الى طاوله المفاوضات لحل الصراع
بينه وبين الرئيس
المشكك في شرعيه فوز بايدن وفي رئاسته
ولذلك قد تبدو خشيه السودانيين في محلها
من فكره التدخل الوسطاء الدوليين لحل صراع
داخلي يجب ان يحلب بوسائله
فالوسطاء الدوليون والاقليبيون ليس في
سجلهم تحقيق سلام في بلد ما ولا يضل بهم
ذلك خاصه اذا كان ذلك البلد هو السودان
حيث تتقاطعوا مصالح ومطامع الداخلين في
شؤونه عبر اختراقات في عسكريته وفي سياسته
وتفاوض الطرفين في السودان اذا تم لن يكون
في احسن احواله غير ترحيل للازمه الى
المستقبل الى حرب اخرى غير هذه
معنى من واشنطن الخبير في شؤون السودان
ومؤلف كتاب ديمقراطيه السودان غير
المكتمله اهلا وسهلا بك
هل نحن امام صراع غير مسبوق لان الاشكال
القائم في السودان ايضا اشكال غير مسبوق
في الدول
المبارك انا
ما بعرف
انجليزي
انا اعتقد ان ما نشهده هو نخشاه هذا
النزاع وان يتحول الى حرب اقليميه الاسره
الدوليه تركز جهودها على
تلافي اقحام المنطقه في هذا النزاع لان
ذلك من شانه ان يساعده الى نزاع اسوا
بكثير ليس فقط بالنسبه للسودانيين بل لما
تبقى من شمال وشرق افريقيا يعني لماذا هذا
التخوف من حرب اقليميه البعض يتحدث عن
امكانيه حرب اهليه في السودان لماذا هذا
الخوف من حرب اقليميه ما المؤشرات
نحن نامل لا يحصل ذلك واعتقد ان الاسره
الدوليه لا تدخر وسعا حاليا من اجل تلافي
ذلك
واعتقد ان دبلوماسيين في الولايات المتحده
وفي الاوساط الاوروبيه
ينظرون الى تدخل مصر وهل تدعم قوات
المسلحه السودانيه وهل ان روسيا والامارات
تدعم قوات الدعم السريعه اعتقد ان هذا سوف
يكون
حاسما في الاسابيع المقبله وكذلك هناك ضغط
من اجل توصل الى وقف لاطلاق النار وحل
النزاع باسهل واسرع ما يمكن الان هناك
اشارات خجوله عن هذا التدخل الذي تشير
اليه لو امتدت المعارك في السودان الى
اكثر الى فتره اطول هل تعتقد بان هذه
الاطراف
يتضح دخولها بشكل كبير
وهو السر طبعا اتمنى لا يحصل ذلك لان ذلك
سوف يؤدي الى كارثه ليس فقط للسودان بل
المنطقه ايضا
اعتقد
انه
لو شاركت المنطقه وتلك الدول في هذا
النزاع سوف يصعد الى ما لا تحمد عقباه
وبالتالي من الضروري ان لا تتدخل ولا
تنخرط هذه الاطراف في النزاع واي دعم
خارجي
يحصل حاليا يجب ان يتوقف
لاننا
بحاجه للتوصل لي الى وقف لاطلاق النار
لانهاء النزاع باسرع ما يمكن لهذا تعمل
الاسره الدوليه على ما اراه مع
الدبلوماسيه من تلك الدول حتى تستخدم كل
قواها وكل قدراتها لانهاء النزاع وهل هناك
افاق لهذه الوساطه
ان الامل الذي يحضون الان هو ان ينفذ وقف
اطلاق النار الذي بدا خلال عيد الفطر هناك
الكثير من التقارير حين اتحدث الى
المدنيين في الخرطوم انه لا ينفذ بطريقه
كامله اعتقد انه اول اختبار
ومحطه رئيسيه وحساسه يجب ان تضغط
لتنفيذها على كافه القوى الاقليميه على
الطرفين من اجل تنفيذها شكرا جزيلا لك
عيد الفطر هذا العام حل بطعم الحرب
والازمات الانسانيه على السودانيين
وتتواصلوا نداءات المنظمات التابعه للامم
المتحده لوقف الاقتتال والسماح لموظفي
الاغاثه بايصال المساعدات الانسانيه
وتقديم الرعايه للمحتاجين تتزامن النداءات
الدوليه مع حديث لنقابه الاطباء
السودانيين للجزيره بان عددا من
المستشفيات خرجت عن الخدمه وان الامر ينذر
بوضع كارثي
اصوات الرصاص
ورائحه البخور السوداني برائحه البارود
والجثث على الطرقات غيبت مظاهر الفرح
بحلول الفطر المبارك وحضرت تفاصيل حرب
تدور في شوارع الخرطوم ودارفور وغيرها من
مناطق البلاد من سرق البهجه من السودانيين
في هذا العيد غامر كثيرون بحياتهم للتنقل
الى المساجد من اجل اداء الصلاه في وطن
يحتاج الى كثير من الدعاء حتى لا يغرق
اكثر فئه حرب البسته ثوب الحداد منذ السبت
الدامي الوضع الانساني المتدهور في زمن
السلام يتجاوز الان مرحله الكارثه مع كل
هدنه لا تحترم وكل وعد بفتح ممرات انسانيه
فقدت منظمه الهجره الدوليه احد موظفيها
نعته في بيان ذكرت فيه بعض تفاصيل الحادثه
وقالت انه كان يتنقل مع اسرته بالقرب من
الابيض عندما قتل بالرصاص في منطقه
اشتباكات قبل الهجره الدوليه كانت منظمه
الاغذيه خسرت ثلاثه من موظفيها في دارفورد
وعلقت لاحقا عملها بسبب تدهور الوضع
الامني في بلد ثلث سكانه يعتمدون على
مساعدات المنظمه الامميه حتى المنظمات
التي لم توقف عملها رسميا هي اليوم عاجزه
عن تقديم خدماتها وايصال المساعدات
المطلوبه بالحاح للمحتاجين رسمت اليونيسف
صوره مرعبه عن اوضاع الاطفال خلال وقبل
ايام الصراع الاخير قتلت تسعه اطفال منذ
بدء الاشتباكات اصيب ما لا يقل عن 50 طفلا
اعلنت المنظمه التوقف الرعايه الاساسيه
التي كانت تقدم لنحو خمسين الف طفل يعانون
من سوء التغذيه الحاد قبل المواجهات
الاخيره كان اكثر من 600 الف طفل يعانون
من سوء التغذيه الحاد
يحدث كل هذا في بلد هو ثالث منتج للذهب في
افريقيا جعلته الحروب وحسابات السياسه
والمصالح الداخليه والاقليميه والدوليه من
بين الدول الفقيره عالميا تتواصل نداءه
الاستغاثه من داخل وخارج السودان لتقديم
المساعده للمرافق الطبيه العاجزه عن علاج
المرضى وانقاذ الارواح الوضع الانساني
والطبي سيء للغايه حتى هذه المستشفيات
التي نتحدث عنها هي مستشفيات اساسيه
يمكنها التقديم الخدمه الطبيه للجرحى
والمصابين هذه المستشفيات هي على حافه
الاغلاق في اي لحظه نحن ارسلنا عدد من
النداءات
الى كل الجهات اصدقاء السودان بالخارج
للضغط على الطرفي الصراع لوقتها للحرب
العباسيه فورا وفتح ممرات امنه اعلنت
نقابه الاطباء السودانيين ارتفاع عدد
المستشفيات المتوقفه عن العمل في الخرطوم
وولايات اخرى الى 55 من اصل 78 مضيفه ان
اربعه مستشفيات في الابيض تعرضت للقس
اول ايام عيد الفطر لم يكن سعيدا ابدا على
السودانيين سواء منهم عالقون وسط معارك
لطائله منها سوى الخراب او منهم في الخارج
يتابعون اخبار اهل ووطن تحت النار وسماء
لم ينقش عنها دخان الانفجارات
هذا وقد درسنا مراسل الجزيره محمد الطيب
من الخرطوم اجواء استقبال السكان للعيد في
ظل احتدام المعارك
وصلاتها في الساح
ات لكنهم هذه المره يصلونها في المساجد
لمن استطاع الى ذلك سبيلا اذ لم تعد كثير
من الباحات امنه لا سيما في تلك المناطق
بالخرطوم حيث تحتتم المعارك والحمد لله
يعني صلينا بامان لكن لاول مره نصلي داخل
المسجد نسبه الى اصوات الرصاص ومضرو به
البلاد نزل الله ان يحقن الدفاع العيد
ينبغي ان يعيشه الناس بفرح بسرور ببهجه
كبارا وصغارا ولكن للاسف الشديد يعني نبي
الاصوات والرعب الذي يعني شاع في النفوس
والقلوب فهو جعل الناس لا يتمتعون بفرحه
العيد الحقيقيه التي ينبغي ينبغي ان
يعيشونها
معظم المنازل هنا لم تجد سبيلا للتجهيز
للعيد واعداد مخبوزاته نتيجه المخاطر
المرتبطه بالتحرك وشلل كثير طال المحل
التجاريه حتى صنعت حاله من التوجس في
وجوههم بالاستمرار الافتتالي مده سبعه
ايام ان شاء الله ربنا سبحانه وتعالى يفرج
علينا ويزيد من هذه الاحزان والهموم في
الراس
من رب العالمين ربنا يفرجها علينا بس
مستنيه رب العالمين انه الحاجه دي تزيل
كده والسعاده ترجع للناس والابتسامه ترجع
الناس تتواصل عيد يبدو انه منقوص الفرحه
ولم تكتمل اركانه بالامان ولم الشمل هكذا
استقبل سكان الخرطوم عيد الفطر المبارك
ورغم ذلك لا تزال هناك امال عند كثيرين ان
تضع الحرب اوزارها سريعا حتى تسكن
الطمانينه في البيوت
القتال الدير بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع اشتد اواره حتى في يوم العيد
وتوسعت جبهاته في مناطق متفرقه جنوبي
العاصمه ووسطها وهو ما يفاقم سوء الاوضاع
ويزيد من معاناه الناس
محمد الطيب الجزيره جنوب غربي الخرطوم
انضموا الينا من جنيف فولدي المتحدث باسم
المنظمه الدوليه للهجره اهلا وسهلا بك في
اجواء السودان الحاليه كيف يمكن للمنظمات
الانسانيه الدوليه ان تعمل
الوضع صعب جدا بالنسبه الى هذه المنظمات
حاليا في السودان بسبب كثافه القتال في
السودان
اليوم وللاسف ان احد اعضاء فريقنا وهو
جنسيه من الجنسيه السودانيه عمره 49
عاما ولديه
طفل ولد حديثا توفي في مدينه الابيض وهو
يحاول ان يجد له مكانا امنا خارجا
اذا مقري عمله
احد افراد الطاقه
تلقى رصاصه وهو يحاول ان ينقل اسرته وتوفي
اذا هذا ينقل ماساه طواقم المنظمات
الانسانيه الدوليين بالاضافه الى الاف
السودانيين الذين كرسوا حياتهم من اجل ان
يساعدوا المواطنين السودانيين اخوتهم وهم
يعانون الامرين منذ سنوات وذلك بسبب
عدم قدرتهم على العمل في هذه البيئه
المعاديه والصعبه جدا
تعزينا طبعا لهذه الخساره هل يمكن ان يؤدي
هذا الجو الى توقف تقريبا شبه كامل لعمل
المنظمات الانسانيه الدوليه
اعتقد ان الامين العام قد اوضح
ان توقعات او انه مطلوب منا ان نستمر في
توصيل المساعدات الانسانيه الى شعب
السوداني نحن نتحدث عن ثلث سكان في
السودان وبالتحديد
15.8 مليون شخص هم بامس الحاجه الى
المساعدات على الانسانيه
وطبعا هذه الحاجات تزداد افاداحه وذلك
نتيجه اعمال العنف الحاليه
المساعده الانسانيه التي يعتمدون عليها هي
لا تصل اليهم في سياق المستجدات الاخيره
لان الوضع خطير جدا هل تبلغ
تصوركم للمرحله المقبله على اسوا
الاحتمالات
اعتقد ان هناك الكثير من عمليه التخطيط
وصيغه الخطط البديله التي تشرع على قدم
وساق بين طواقم المنظمات الدوليه والاسره
الدوليه نبقى متفائلين بتنفيذ وقف اطلاق
النار وطبعا هذا هو الاساس يجب اسكات صوت
السلاح والرصاص من اجل ان نتمكن من الخروج
من منازلنا والقيام بعمالنا في السودان
تلبيه لحاجات مئات الاف الاشخاص الذين
الليله هذه الامسيه وربما في الايام
المقبله سوف يجدون انفسهم عالقين في
منازلهم يحاولون ان يتفادوا الرصاص
والانفجارات في مقرات مختلفه من البلاد
شكرا جزيلا لك من جنيف
قال وزير الدفاع الامريكي اوستن ان ما
تركز ما تركز عليه الاداره الامريكيه هو
التاكد من الاستمرار فيما وصفه بالتخطيط
الحكيم بشان السودان والحفاظ على الاكبر
عدد ممكن من الخيارات للرئيس جو بايدن
فيما يتعلق باجلاء موظفيه السفاره واضاف
اوستون ان البنتاجون نشر قوات امريكيه في
مسرح العمليه لضمان توفير اكبر عدد ممكن
من الخيارات اذا طلب منها القيام بشيء ما
في السودان
هذا وقد اعلن وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انه
تحدث مع البرهان وحمايه الخميس ودعاهما
للالتزام بوقف اطلاق النار كما دعبلينكن
الطرفين في السودان لوقف القتال للسماح
بوصول المساعدات الانسانيه وتمكين جميع
المدنيين بمن فيهم الموظفون الدبلوماسيون
من الوصول الى بر الامان
ينضم الينا من واشنطن مراسله الجزيره عبد
الفتاح فايد اهلا وسهلا بك عبد الفتاح
ما اسوا ما تستعد اليه الاداره الامريكيه
في التعامل مع السودان الان
بالتاكيد محمد الاسوا هو ان تكون هناك
مشكله في عمليات الاجلاء من السودان
الجلاء الباحثات الدبلوماسيه والرعايه
الامريكيين هذا ما عبر عنه بشكل صريح رئيس
لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه في مجلس النواب
الامريكي مايك ماكول في رساله الى وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه حصلنا عليها قبل قليل
وهي التي
يحذر فيها الاداره الامريكيه من سيناريو
مشابه لما وصفه باخطاء الانسحاب الامريكي
من افغانستان وبالتالي هناك مخاوف حقيقيه
لعل هذا محمد هو ما يقف خلف تاخر قرار
اجلاء الرعايه الامريكيه من السودان اعلان
الاداره الامريكيه ان قرارا لم يتخذ حتى
الان بهذا الشان وبان الوضع الامني في
السودان لا يسمح بعمليه الاجلاء في الوقت
الراهن هناك حاله استنفار محمد لدى
الاداره الامريكيه على كافه المساواه
السياسيه والعسكريه
والدبلوماسيه اليوم فقط البيت الابيض
الخارجيه الامريكيه عبر اكثر من اطلاله
سواء عبر التصريح اليومي للمتحدث باسم
الخارجيه المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه
الامريكيه او ايضا عبر البيان الذي اصدره
وزير الخارجيه
وكذلك هيئه الاركان الامريكيه الجنرال
مارك ميلي في التصريحات التي قالها
للجزيره عبر مصادر خاصه للجزيره حصل عليها
الزميل فادي منصور وايضا عبر كذلك وزاره
الدفاع الامريكيه البنتاجون وزير الدفاع
الود اوستن كل هذا الاستنفار تقول الاداره
الامريكيه انه لا اولويه تفوق وتعلو على
اجلاء البعثات الدبلوماسيه والرعايه
الامريكيه الخاصه بعد تاكيد مقتل مواطن
امريكي في السودان ولكن ايضا محمد هناك
التحذيرات المستمره من ان تفاقم الاوضاع
في السودان هو يضر بامن المنطقه بشكل عام
هناك قلق متزايد لدى الاداره الامريكيه
كذلك الاعلان الاول عن نشر قوات وقدرات
امريكيه في المنطقه ولعل هذا الامر
بالتاكيد هو يؤشر على ان الصراع ما زال في
مراحلها الخطيره وان التطورات في المنطقه
قد تحمل شكرا مخاطر كبيره على المنطقه
بشكل عام لا يمكن محمد فصل مثل هذا
الاستنفار الامريكي بالتاكيد عن صراع
النفوذ الدولي والاقليمي في المنطقه خاصه
مع تزايد النفوذ الصيني والروسي في القاره
الافريقيه في السنوات الاخيره محمد نعم
شكرا لك يا عبد الفتاح فايد من واشنطن
نبقى في نفس السياق فقد نقلت عن مسؤول
غربي يعمل على اجلاء دبلوماسيين
الاوروبيين بانه لا خيارات جيده حاليا
يمكن الثقه بها من اجل تنفيذ اجلاء امن
وكان مسئولا اوروبي تحدث لوكاله الصحافه
الفرنسيه عن محاوله تنسيق عمليه اجلاء
محتمله لمواطنه من السودان واضاف ان
الاوضاع الامنيه الحاليه لا تساعد في
المضي قدما في مثل هذه العمليه التي تحتاج
الى وقف اطلاق نار لمده ثلاثه ايام
الان الى اخبارنا الاخرى فقد اقيمت في
المسجد الحرام في مكه المكرمه صباح اليوم
صلاته عيد الفطر بحضور الاف المصلين
وتحتفل معظم الدول الاسلاميه بالعيد اليوم
بينما اعلنت سلطنه عمان وليبيا والمغرب
حلوله السبت لتعذر رؤيه الهلال هناك
وفي المسجد الاقصى المبارك ادى نحو
120,000 فلسطيني صلاه عيد الفطر وسط
اجراءات امنيه فرضها الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
على المداخل المؤديه الى البلده القديمه
في القدس وعلى ابواب المسجد الاقصى
[موسيقى]
وفي تطورات الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
قالت القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه ان
دفاعاتها اسقطت فجر اليوم 8 مسيرات من اصل
12 مسيره ايرانيه السنه استهدف بها الجيش
الروسي العاصمه كياب وعددا من مقاطعات
البلاد واضافت القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه
ان القوات الروسيه شنت خلال الساعات
الماضيه نحو 50 هجوما باستخدام منظومات
صاروخيه على مناطق مدنيه
قال وزير الدفاع الامريكي ان الولايات
المتحده ستبدا تدريب القوات الاوكرانيه
على كيفيه استخدام دبابات ابرامز وصيانتها
في الاسابيع المقبله حيث تواصلوا تسريع
جهودها لادخالها الى ساحه المعركه في اقرب
وقت ممكن وجاء اعلان القرار في وقت يجتمع
فيه قاده الدفاع من جميع انحاء اوروبا
والعالم في قاعده رمشتاين الجويه
الامريكيه بالمانيا في محاوله لتنسيق
تسليم الاسلحه والمعدات الاخرى الى
اوكرانيا
من جهته قلنا من العام لحلف الناتو
ستولتنبرغ ان جميع حلفاء النيتو اتفقوا
على ان تصبح اوكرانيا عضوا في الحلف في
نهايه المطاف
اكد وزير الخارجيه الصيني
ان جانبي مضيق تايوان يعودان الى الصين
وان من الصواب والملائم ان تتمسك الصين
بسيادتها انه خلال الاونه الاخيره صدرت
تصريحات وصفها بالسخيفه تتهم الصين بتغيير
الوضع الراهن وتقويض السلام والاستقرار
عبر مضيق تايوان واوضح الوزير الصيني ان
القوه الانفصاليه الداعيه لاستقلال تايوان
كما قال ومجموعه من الدول تحاول زعزعه
الوضع الراهن محذرا من قال انهم يلعبون
بالنار بانهم سيحترقون بها
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
[تصفيق]
الله اكبر
الاهلي
[موسيقى]
كل كل المستشفيات المنطقه خرجت الخدمه
اكبر مستشفى مستشفى
الله اكبر
يا الله
اكبر الله اكبر